as tu eu quand
sa seule adresse pour demain ok mais
comment voir
8800gt message mail en vous êtes très
élégant mais bouger sur la couleur le
reste je deviens un peu relou ces
derniers temps
[Musique]
tout va passer partout c'est toi la
responsable c'est quoi ton street les
assidus mais vie si mon temps à ça
puisque de la sécu mais tu me grâce à
son charme
au mieux c'est
oui
allez vous arrêter pour florange non je
vous aime parcours ça être dans un temps
fou d'accord
après je dis quoi je ne puis renoncer à
vos amis ha ce bernard
la personne ne vous oblige à rester
tercel mobile mais moi j'aime faire mon
travail me faire bien moi non van persie
loin
et
là on me laisse longue 500
à l'amour agence mary ou savez ce que
c'est l'amour
nous on aimerait le faire le guignol
sans renoncer à mon amour je renoncerais
un mec est méritée oui pas de jambes et
à la plage
[Musique]